i got [ __ ]
lucky as [ __ ]
that my british counterpart ksi called
me out for a boxing match oh oh [ __ ]
people joke
i thought people joke they say you know
chaos i saved your career right because
he called me out the box and it gave me
an opportunity to literally
start my
potential redemption by fighting
my way back yeah fighting so fighting to
a first
first
earn a chance to be forgiven
wait a second i made a mistake i get i
[ __ ] made a mistake
but like
stand by for one second i don't think
that mistake is me
yeah hey step 8 or earn a chance to be
forgiven did you stop vlogging between
yeah those two pictures yeah oh okay
yeah i thought that you chose fighting
no dude because ksi called me out people
and people joke
this is funny
you get some good alpha on this show dog
people joke they go uh
in case i saved your career right so you
gave me a chance to box twice like
really like make a name for myself and
earn respect in a different way and show
my character my real character
they say um you know case i saved your
career
and in a way he did dude
and you know
i'll always be grateful for it
and then years later i was able to bring
him an opportunity called prime
hydration
and we'll see what happens but
based on uh
current sales we're doing pretty well
hopefully the product you know continues
to
become
you know mainstream hydration drink and
i want to say one day
that uh
case i saved my career but i made him a
billionaire
that's fun
so he's cool i think it's like i think
it's good oh that's a great story cool
right do you feel
it is that why you reconciled with him
[Music]
because i know you guys were beefing and
it felt kind of real
how did i reconcile with him yeah
the beef was [ __ ] real
the beef was real we hated each other
that's why this story is so like that's
why yeah prime has an innate like
um
sense of relatability in in hope that
like
you can amend you can make friends you
can we can connect like
case i and i [ __ ] hated each other
beef was real
then um
he he beat me in the rematch by that by
that by a point it was that weird like
two-point deduction the whole thing and
like it it
he won and i didn't
it didn't affect me because i think
because our japan had happened i know
what it's like to like lose and i never
really felt like i just don't feel like
i lose i feel like
i said this in a [ __ ] ironically diss
track i made against antonio brown
that's weird but there's a line in it
that like i was the most relatable line
ever it was for me it was um yeah i took
an l but i never really lose mm-hmm
because i was thinking hell but like
just learning in that you know so
i learned that like ksi and i are like
like
[ __ ] the beef we're like the same person
across the pond right like we're like in
a weird way we're really like and then
um
i did a show for him he he invited me
because it was it was good for his uh or
not a show it was a um podcast right it
was like it was like a it was like a
show to promote his album drop yeah it's
like like an hour long special and i did
the spot
and he told me outside he's like okay
i'm surprised you said yes to this like
what do you mean bro i don't like take
any of that [ __ ] personal
like since the last time we had fought
i've gone i'd gone through so much
personal growth um
that like we like i just didn't care
about any qualms we had in the past i
didn't mean anything i don't take any of
it personal
whatever we had a good go
and i was like all right yeah and then
we had him on the podcast
[ __ ] got along one of the best
podcasts i think our highest viewed as
well yeah i realized i'm just a lot more
like this kid like than we are different
right
i brought him
prime uh
because i thought it'd be
an incredible business move with an
incredible story
and and he's and he's an amazing partner
you know it's like we it's like we just
like yeah it's like a weird yang thing
would you feel away if
he fought jake
that's that's gonna be [ __ ] up doug
yeah that's gonna be [ __ ] up you know
they're already like beefing online no
yeah
why would that be [ __ ] up
because when's my business partner who i
already had the [ __ ] feud with bro i
already had the back and i don't
care to do that again
i know it'd be it's
[ __ ] that
he's my business partner i like him
i don't want to go back to the beef
and the other is my [ __ ] blood
during prime [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no more
[Laughter]